alors ici vous avez une statue de sainte
catherine du 15e siècle et vous avez la
route qui a indiqué que son martyre
maintenant quand ils ont à la musique
eh bien oui continuons la visite mais
essayons de quitter malgré leur aspect
sympathique les côtés trop traditionnel
des musées d'autrefois
le musée lorrain de nancy a su faire
peau neuve se moderniser n'y at-il pas
maintenant une muséologie de toute
manière un sérieux renouveau que nous
évoquons avec son conservateur je
l'avais shoes est conservateur du musée
lorrain nancy et je crois qu'il faut
tout de suite enlevez une idée fausse un
musée ce n'est pas un ramassis de
poussière n'est ce pas à redon nous
essayons au contraire de lutter contre
la poussière non seulement matérielle
monde en salle mais de lutter même
contre cette idée qu'un musée peut être
une chose vieillotte ennuyeuse
poussiéreuse
nous essayons de présenter ce que nous
allons nos collections d'une façon
vraiment vivant d'une façon agréable et
en même temps d'une façon didactique qui
fasse comprendre qu'il fasse à prendre
puisqu'il s'agit de faire comprendre je
suppose qu'il ya une sorte de plan dans
ce musée examiné witt m nous avons un
plan qui nous est imposée par la nature
même du musée d'abord keita musée
historique
donc nous devons faire comprendre le
passé l'histoire du pays
et avec ce thème nous avons présenté les
collections de façon que le visiteur qui
visitent l'ensemble du musée puisse
avoir une idée du développement de la
région d'alors
depuis les origines depuis la
préhistoire jussieu pratiquement jusqu'à
nos jours
sans négliger du toit la présentation
d'objectifs sont là surtout pour le côté
esthétique et bien ils ne sont pas là
surtout pour le côté ses tics mais le un
objet d'art n'est ce pas une oeuvre
d'art est l'expression la plus belle de
son temps et par conséquent une oeuvre
d'art en même temps qu'elle procure aux
visiteurs jouissance esthétique une
satisfasse une satisfaction esthétique
est en même temps un document sur une
époque les deux choses sont inséparables
enfin monsieur l'abbé il faut préciser
que vous avez mise en route la
présentation de deux nouvelles salles
oui qui rentre d'ailleurs tout à fait
dans cet esprit d'une part nous avons
ajouté à nos salles du xviiie siècle une
salle consacrée aux sciences au 18e
siècle et en lorraine comme partout
n'est ce pas on a eu un très grand
engouement pour les sciences cette
époque en particulier la cour du roi
ceni stanislas personnellement
s'intéressait beaucoup à cela et il a
fait des inventions de machines qui
d'ailleurs marchait plus ou moins bien
me faire peu importe et autour de lui on
s'y intéresser et nous avons des objets
qui viennent de stanislas et de son
entourage
mais votre sale juive a dû vous poser
bien des ennuis suppose que vous avez dû
vous renseigner pour cause elle m'a posé
des problèmes
bien sûr car c'est assez complexe c'est
particulier mais en même temps elle
donné beaucoup de satisfaction parce que
j'ai appris beaucoup de choses en la
présentant en somme j'ai voulu faire
comprendre avec les objets que nous
possédions ce qu'était la vie juive et
en même temps ce qu'étaient les
communautés juives de lorraine
et bien je vous remercie et nous avons
vu que le musée lorrain n'est pas un
musée austère c'est beaucoup de choses